Rachel thank you so much for being here
I am so sorry for what you and everyone
in your community have been going
through it is it's it's it's almost too
much to comprehend how are you
personally holding up and if you could
take us through some of your efforts oh
my gosh thank you it's um it's been a
long five days so I apologize I'm a
little a little weary over here it's a
it's a very humbling experience being
out here it's just amazing how a lot of
us you know the horse community we're
really coming together
everyone is donating what they can if
they can't their time their you know
their finances their resources it really
does take a village to help everyone out
here and you know all of our hearts go
out so we are all working together very
closely to just come together and be out
here for the people their animals their
properties their neighbors their friends
their family it's um it's it's been very
devastating being out here Rachel you
know what I was so heartened to see
through all of this heartbreak and
tragedy was that people were putting
aside their differences there you know
and political different all and just
what can I do to help you what do you
need well how can I get you a truck a
trailer feed can you could bring your
animal to my home and and we need to do
more of that in this country I mean I'm
a political commentator but the best of
our country comes out in a time of
crisis and that applies to politicians
who should you know sometimes button it
and not comment on things and people
like me but I just applaud all of you
for doing what we should do to help our
fellow man it's awesome thank you thank
you so much you have a you know NorCal
livestock evacuation and rescue this is
what we're about we're about you know
we're a bunch of volunteers that are put
together we work individually with the
owners so you know if the air is clear
we're able to come out here and get
their animals we are closely working
with you know CHP with the Rangers with
the game wardens you know we're out here
wanting to make sure that we are also
safe as well as the property so when we
go in here and get these animals then we
can go ahead and bring them
back to you know the volunteers that you
know and the other certified help that
are working closely with the
veterinarians to get the animals the
care that they need you know so they can
be reunited and it is amazing how much
social media has gone on I mean you know
all of us every other once in a while
you know we're like oh man we don't want
to get on Facebook today what's going to
be on there but it has been amazing at
Instagram Facebook Twitter you guys it
is a beautiful are Rachel thank you so
much an incredible report and don't lose
your own life as much as we want to save
our animals look out for yourself too my
friend